partie gekommen zu einer neuen halle
deutschland woche schön dass sie mit
dabei sind das erste schöne wochenende
mit sonne und mit einer kontaktsperre
liegt hinter uns wir gucken wie die
menschen damit umgegangen sind
das ist ein thema in unserem heutigen
corona kompakt unser
nachrichtenüberblick beginnt aber in new
york sirenen und blaulicht ein kleines
dankeschön der feuerwehr an alle helfer
die korona krise trifft new york schwer
sowie krankenhäuser und das personal
sind überlastet es fehlt an
medizinischer ausrüstung bereits jetzt
gibt es provisorische krankenstationen
bei denen soldaten helfen infizierte zu
versorgen
heute wurde bekannt dass in einem new
york hat so ein tiger positiv auf das
corona virus getestet wurde
vermutlich wurde das tier von einem
pfleger ohne symptome angesteckt die
malaysische tigerkatze nadia hat
trockenen husten und atembeschwerden der
zoo rechnet aber mit einer vollständigen
genesung der tigerdame für besucher ist
der zoo seit drei wochen geschlossen
der tiergarten im landkreis aurich steht
vor ganz anderen problemen
kurz nach der eröffnung mussten sie
wieder schließen keine besucher keine
einnahmen
die leiterin des tiergartens steht vor
dem finanziellen kollaps der erste monat
geht der zweite monat wird dann
dramatisch bauarbeiten werden gestoppt
mitarbeiter in die kurzarbeit geschickt
aber ein kostenpunkt läuft auch während
der korona krise weiter die versorgung
der tiere
das wissen auch die treuen besucher
viele spenden spontan geld oder futter
wir sind überwältigt
also das muss man ganz ehrlich wie viele
leute auch tolle ideen haben nur
futterspenden sollte man telefonisch
absprechen denn nicht alles was
gespendet wird kann man auch tatsächlich
verfüttern ein herz für die
einsatzkräfte im kampf gegen korona
zeigen immer mehr hotels in hamburg
herzförmige beleuchtungen an den
fenstern und fassaden sollen den helfern
mut machen die buchstaben thx leuchten
in den nachthimmel
eine abkürzung für fans ein großes danke
ein leuchtendes zeichen der solide
ried mit herzlichen grüßen aus hamburg
ganz besondere töne schlägt die
feuerwehr dorsten am sonntag an
mit trompete und euphonium geht es auf
die drehleiter 15 meter nach oben
der gedanke trieb und schon länger um
auch in dieser form unsere verbundenheit
mit der bevölkerung zu zeigen
eine schöne art den menschen den marsch
zu blasen
dass johns hopkins institut vermeldet
heute 100.000 186 infizierte und 28.700
genesene professor wurde platte ist
virologe an der uni mainz und jetzt zu
gast professor platter heute kam die
meldung dass österreich die an die
korona maßnahmen ein bisschen lockern
möchte ab meist dass zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt eine gute oder eine schlechte
idee möchte jedes land muss schauen was
es wirklich zu zahlen hat die berühmten
zahlen der neuinfektionen daran abhängig
natürlich kann man darüber nachdenken ob
man entsprechend maßnahmen wie zum
beispiel eben diese bestimmte läden
wieder geöffnet und dann eben die dinge
wieder etwas lockerer lässt aber wie
gesagt da muss man nicht sich im die
zahlen entsprechend anschauen
das ist klar vielen dank für die antwort
und sie sind ja gleich noch hier und
beantwortete einige zuschauer fragt ihn
nach heinsberg in nordrhein westfalen
war das erste deutsche epizentrum der
korona pandemie bei einer
karnevalssitzung hatten sich mehrere
menschen angesteckt dass die situation
da nicht eskaliert ist ist auch dem
heinsberger landrat stephan pusch zu
verdanken
auch oliver welke und das team der heute
show die outen sich als fans des
landrats land kreis heinsberg in
nordrhein westfalen die bundeswehr
liefert medizinische ausrüstung in das
deutsche epizentrum der korona krise
dahinter steckt das unermüdliche
engagement von landrat stephan pusch
wir haben immer wieder in den
lagebericht reingeschrieben wir brauchen
material material material und
irgendwann haben sie das gefühl wenn man
kurz davor stehen wirklichen krankenhaus
schließen zu müssen weil ihnen die
krankenhausleitung sagt wir haben noch
für 12 tage masken und schutzkittel und
ich kann es nicht verantworten die leute
dann ohne das arbeiten zu lassen was
nachvollziehbar ist
dann müssen sie laut geben und dann
jetzt auch nicht darum wählen sie dann
an wenn ich bin ja eigentlich dann als
landrat ein kleiner prinz und wenn sie
dann an wellen dann müssen noch mal die
großen runde an treffen mit erfolg an
diesem tag bekommt der landkreis für
seine krankenhäuser 18.000 schutzmasken
8000 kittel und zwei beatmungsgeräte
geliefert und dennoch der halb gefüllte
lkw deckt bei weitem nicht den bedarf
doch ohne diese lieferung hätte der
landrat möglicherweise kliniken
schließen müssen
jetzt kann der betrieb
mal weitergehen ich bin sehr dankbar als
landrat des kreises sein dass wir heute
diese lieferung bekommen haben
es war reicht das nur für zwei bis drei
tage aber es ist ein wichtiges signal
für uns hier im kreis möchte dass wir
nicht alleine gelassen werden vom rest
der republik
die medizinische versorgung ist nur eins
von vielen problemen die landrat pusch
momente an gleichzeitig lösen muss die
wirtschaft liegt am boden
viele menschen sind ängstlich und ratlos
stephan pusch hält täglich kontakt zur
bevölkerung per facebook video liebe
mitbürger mitbürger mit lasse die finger
davon den einkaufswagen voll zu räumen
mit sachen die da irgendwann
verschlimmern und diese irgendwann nicht
mehr brauchen in diesem sinne danke
schön und als beeskow und 30.000
menschen folgen der facebook seite
inzwischen jetzt hat sich da auch heute
show moderator oliver welke zu wort
gemeldet die menschen im kreis heinsberg
viele grüße und die allerbesten wünsche
vom kompletten team der heute schon was
er durchmacht und durchgemacht haben in
den letzten wochen ist extrem und wenn
man sie mit wie viel ruhe und
zusammenhalt der das hingekriegt haben
kann man nur sagen alle mit ab und
natürlich herzlich glück und hier habe
das meine ich ohne wird den besten land
der welt grüßen einzubringen so etwas
tut gut in diesen harten tagen für
landrat pusch oft fühlt er sich in einem
film der jenseits seiner bisherigen
vorstellungen liebt denn wenn mir einer
gesagt hätte spielt das doch mal als
krisenszenario durch doch jeder gesagt
also leute kommen die home steht hoch
krisenszenario erdbeben krisenszenario
totaler stromausfall krisenszenario aber
so ein gau so ein größter anzunehmender
unfall wie eine weltweite pandemie
das war doch eher was aus den
lehrbüchern doch jetzt ist denn irgendwo
in deutschland realer als in seinem land
kreis heinsberg
es ist gespenstisch still da wo sonst
bunt laut und voll ist auf der hamburger
reeperbahn trotzdem dröhnt aus einigen
klubs laute musik und trotz des
kontaktverbot treffen sich auch noch
einige grüppchen illegal
das haben wir gar ordnungsamt
kontrolliert momentan deswegen ganz
genau 20 uhr dienstbeginn für christin
wassermann und andreas anhorn von der
hamburger bereitschaftspolizei
die beamten sind in der innenstadt
unterwegs menschenansammlungen sind
verboten partys erst recht bei verstößen
droht eine geldstrafe
bei lokalen die geöffnet haben da geht
es dann teilweise in den tausender
bereich also 2500 euro 4.000 euro bis zu
5000 euro und bei mehrfachen verstößen
kann das ganze dann auch verdoppelt
werden
die straßen wie leergefegt das
kontaktverbot und der seit freitag
geltende bußgeldkatalog zeigen offenbar
wirkung der kann ab standhält wird zur
kasse gebeten
die meisten menschen halten sich dran
doch dann entdecken die beamten vor
allem kiosk vier personen die offenbar
gegen dieses verbot verstoßen aber von
allen leuten die auf die besagte dass
wir genau mit zwei leuten so genau und
deswegen stellt das ganze eine
ordnungswidrigkeit dar deswegen muss ich
selber als betroffene eine
ordnungswidrigkeit belehren das ist auch
mit dem bußgeld bewehrt 150 euro für
jeden beteiligten dieser ansammlung das
ist der regel koste regelt bußgeldsatz
und sollten die schon vorher aufgefallen
sein
denn eventuell sogar eine verdopplung
oder eben möglicherweise auch eine
vervierfachung des bußgeldes je nachdem
wie häufig aufgefallen sind
die maßnahmen sollen die verbreitung des
virus verlangsamen damit das
gesundheitssystem nicht überlastet wird
dass sie mit ihrem fehlverhalten sich
und andere gefährden will die gruppe
nicht einsehen
einer wird aggressiv
was ist denn los so haben sie das jetzt
haben sie haben sie jetzt einmal
verstanden was sie falsch gemacht haben
okay gut denn lassen sie das in zukunft
wird demnach und dann gehen sie jetzt
los und zwar bitte alleine schon mal in
die richtung dankeschön
die sind ein bisschen unkooperativ so
wie ich die situation wahrnehmen so von
außen ist das möchte sich gerne auch
zusammenfinden ein bisschen was zusammen
in geselliger runde trinken das ist
natürlich nicht mehr möglich mit der
verordnung deshalb stößt man manchmal
eben auf unverständnis
gut dann schon abend die
bußgeldbescheide kommen per post
christian wassermann und andreas anhorn
setzen ihre streife auf der reeperbahn
fort wegen der korona krise sind alle
clubs und bars geschlossen
eine atmosphäre wie in einem horrorfilm
gespenstisch hier auf der großen
freiheit sonst ist die proppevoll voller
menschen um diese urteile auf dem
samstag
und jetzt ist hier einfach gar niemand
die läden sind zu die lichter sind
größtenteils aus hier sind alle so und
verhalten sich alle so wie es sein soll
doch dann der nächste einsatz ein
anwohner hat gemeldet dass aus einem
club laute musik dröhnt
die beamten gehen der angeblichen
ruhestörung nach
die polizei genau prüfe auch immer ganz
kurz rein kommen und uns prima sollte
der klub trotz des verbots geöffnet
haben droht nach dem neuen
bußgeldkatalog eine strafe von bis zu
5000 euro
andreas anhorn klärt die anwesenden auf
wir haben bürgerhinweis nur gekommen
hier gehen rein machen deine party
machen den rollern zu wir wollen nur
einmal ganz kurz nach dem rechten
schauen dass das eben nicht so ist dann
schauen wir einmal kurz um die ecke von
partygästen fehlt jede spur
es sind nur zwei personen im club und
wie sich herausstellt haben die eine
sondergenehmigung für das aufzeichnen
einer musikshow das hier ist natürlich
kein gaststättenbetrieb als solcher der
hier stattfindet sondern einfach nur
natürlich ja eine live show wie man uns
hier mitgeteilt hat man streamt das
internet ja eine musikshow und insofern
ist das alles gut hier treffen eben
nicht unkontrolliert menschen sonst wie
sonst aufeinander
die eben zusammen feiern also wir müssen
alle aufpassen dass wir abstand
zueinander halten
wir appellieren auch in unserem stream
dass die leute zu hause bleiben sollen
und eben abstand zu halten
deswegen machen wir das damit nicht aus
müssen wir kommen zu denen im wohnzimmer
hier hat alles seine ordnung der fall
ist damit für die beamten erledigt sechs
stunden dauert die spätschicht von
andreas an horn und christian wassermann
kurz vor feierabend ziehen die
bereitschaftspolizisten bilanz es ist
sehr still geworden und die meisten
menschen haben das verinnerlicht und da
könnte ich mir sehr gut vorstellen dass
es auch über ostern dann entsprechend
die leute zu hause bleiben und anders in
kontakt treten
das bundesweite kontaktverbot gilt noch
bis zum 19 april
und solange werden polizisten wie
christian wassermann und andreas anhorn
dafür sorgen dass es umgesetzt wird
wer weiß schließlich auch sinnvoll ist
der biologe professor wurde blatter ist
heute unser gast und beantwortet einige
ihrer fragen ins per mail erreicht dann
zum beispiel fragt helmut gast es werden
immer noch viele neue infizierte
gemeldet nach der kontaktsperre müssen
die zahlen doch langsam zurückgehen ja
kontaktsperre kriegen also absolut aber
natürlich gibt es immer noch leute die
arbeiten müssen eben gesundheitswesen
überall in den läden so dass man eben
tatsächlich das nicht unter prozent die
unterbinden kann den kontakt das heißt
aber die zahl geht hat sich langsamer
zurück als einmal komplett alles zu
schließen könnte hubert beben becker
fragt wieviel temperatur verträgt das
virus macht sind zum beispiel mit
kamille zu inhalieren um die viren
abzutöten es gibt viele hausmittelchen
die jetzt genannt werden all die können
nicht wirklich vor der infektion
schützen
die sind ganz nett wenn man fühlt sich
wohl dabei aber im prinzip vor der
infektion wird das nicht wirklich
schützen egal welche dem truck trial
welche temperaturen claudia zettler
fragt ist es möglich dass corona virus
durch gemüse übertragen wird ich weiß
nicht ob ich noch paprika der salate aus
italien oder spanien essen sollte auch
immer wieder gefragt es gibt bislang
keine wirklichen über beweise
wissenschaftliche beweise dass über
nahrungsmittel diese wirklich effizient
übertragen werden dann sind könnte man
wahrscheinlich auch einfach abwaschen
branchen sowieso natürlich aber das ist
sowieso klar
alexander krug fragt kann ich eine
bereits benutzte einen weg
atemschutzmaske im backofen zehn minuten
bei 80 grad desinfizieren und dann
erneut benutzen da habe ich vorsichtig
ob das material das überhaupt aushält
und dann ist es auch nicht sicher
wirklich virus abtöten die 80 grad also
das würde ich wirklich nicht raten wir
was maschine bei 60 grad wäre aber eine
maske dann ja die aber dieses normalen
haus üblichen also die masken in der
klinik glaube ich halten das auch nicht
unbedingt aus natürlich nicht stoffmaske
wird so etwas aushalten
sabine kaufmann fragt ist jeder ist
jemand ohne manuellen gefährdete als
jemand der seine mandeln noch hat soweit
ich weiß die mandeln ja auch als
barriere für viren und bakterien können
direkt barriere und deshalb orte wo das
immunsystem auch mehr mehr oder weniger
wohnt aber es ist auch hier eigentlich
keine zusätzliche gefährdung geben wenn
man die manchen eben nicht mehr hat
habt ihr kein größeres risiko und auch
keinen größeren schutz
milena man hofer kann ich testen lassen
ob ich unwissentlich bereits eine krone
infektion hatte
danach ist man ja erstmal immunen solche
tests werden im augenblick entwickelte
und von der industrie bereit gestellt
dass man eben antikörper misst waren
patienten oder bei der person dann kann
man das tatsächlich testen aber im
augenblick ist da auch noch immer nicht
so viel testfahrten dass man das überall
machen kann
das wird aber irgendwann möglich sein
was schätzen sie ungefähr wie lange das
dauern wird
ja das hängt davon ab natürlich es wird
schon noch einige wochen dauern bis wir
das auch wirklich breit einsetzen kann
im augenblick wird mir auch das wiederum
zum beispiel klinikpersonal daneben
einsätzen gut
matschiner jung fragt in südkorea wurden
offenbar corona schnelltests für alle
bürger durchgeführt und damit die
ansteckungsfall verringert
ansteckungsgefahr verringert waren wir
das bei uns nicht
ja wir sind ja auch gehalten jetzt die
test frequenz hoch zu fahren das ist ja
auch geplant auch von der
bundesregierung tatsächlich vorgegeben
das heißt auch bei uns wird natürlich
intensiver getestet werden insbesondere
dann wenn wir tatsächlich diese
maßnahmen wieder etwas aufschieben dann
wird man wie intensiv wird er genau
schauen wo was aufflackert und dann auch
positiv testen
thomas ulrich fragt angenommen das virus
ist 16 bis 21 tage lang ansteckend und
jeder bürger würde ab sofort zu hause
bleiben
dann könnte doch niemand mehr angesteckt
werden oder das ist die
wunschvorstellung dass alle zu hause
bleiben aber es muss ein krankenhaus
funktionieren das muss irgendwie der
supermarkt wie alle leute wollen was
essen das ist theoretisch möglich aber
praktisch natürlich nicht umsetzbar so
was vielen dank für ihre für die
beantwortung der fragen probleme brachte
ja und das gesamte kölner kompakt das
finden sie auch auf youtube auf dem
kanal der zdf- heute- oder schicken sie
uns eine mail an corona kompakte zdf de
einige der fragen reichen wir an unsere
experten dann weiter und beantworten sie
dann hier in der sendung ja und hier
gehts jetzt direkt weiter mit leute
heute